اما على الاراضي الروسيه فقد تعرضت منشات
اليسكا النفطيه باقليم كريسنو داير جنوبيه
البلاد لهجوم بطائره مسيره فقد اعلنت
سلطات الطوارئ الروسيه اندلاعها حريق في
منشاه اليسكي النفطيه وقالت انه تمت سيطره
عليه وافادت وسائل اعلام الروسيه ان
الحريق اندلع نتيجه هجوما بمسيره اوكرانيه
على المنشاه والهجوم هو الثاني على نفس
المنشاه النفطيه خلال 24 ساعه حيث استهدفت
امس الخميس بمسيره اوكرانيه مع ادى الى
اندلاع حريق في احد خزانات الوقود
في الاثناء قال وزير الخارجيه الروسي فان
الهجوم على الكرملين عمل عدائي لافتا الى
ان بلاده سترد بخطوات محدده وملموسه
من الواضح انه كان عملا عدائيا ومن الواضح
تماما ان ارهابي كييف لم يكن بامكانهم
ارتكابه دون علم اسيادهم لن نرد بالحديث
عما اذا كان ذلك يستدعي ردا ام لا بل سنرد
بخطوات محدده وملموسه واود ان اكرر مره
اخرى ان لدينا كثيرا من الصبر وبالحديث عن
موقف واشنطن لقد اطلعت على بيان انتون
بلنكن الذي قال ان الولايات المتحده لن
تملي على اوكرانيا كيف ينبغي ان تدافع عن
سيادتها هذا ربما يوضح كل شيء